we're told in the beginning of each
episode of a certain game show
each contestant picks a certain door out
of three doors
then the game show host randomly picks
one of the two prize
bundles after each round each contestant
receives a prize
based on the door they picked and the
bundle the host picked
matrix a represents the possible prizes
for the first round alright so for
example
if the contestant picks door 3 and the
host picks bundle 1
the prize is 300 but if the contestant
picks
door 3 and the host picks bundle 2 the
prize would be
zero dollars all right and then they say
matrix b represents the possible prizes
for the second round
all right that's fair they also tell us
the second round
can also be a lightning round in this
case
the prizes are doubled
matrix c represents the possible prizes
during a lightning round
complete matrix c so pause this video
and see if you can figure that out and
then we'll work through this together
all right so matrix c is a scenario
where we're dealing with a lightning
round and remember in a lightning round
the prizes are doubled but it's the
second round it's
doubled relative to what it would have
been in the second round
so what it would have been in the second
round is matrix b
so another way to think about it is
matrix c
is going to be equal to 2
times matrix b and we know when we
multiply
a matrix times a scalar like this times
just a number we just multiply each of
these entries by that number
so let's do that if we take 600 and
multiply that by
2 that is going to be 1200
and that makes sense we just said for
each corresponding scenario
the prizes are doubled in a lightning
round so if the contestant picks door
one host picks bundle one instead of six
hundred dollars it's going to be twelve
hundred dollars
keep going instead of two hundred
dollars it's going to be
four hundred dollars all i'm doing here
is i'm multiplying each
risk each of these entries by two
to get the corresponding entry in matrix
e keep going
instead of three hundred dollars here
multiply that by two you're going to get
six hundred dollars
instead of three hundred dollars here
you're going to get six hundred dollars
we're almost there
instead of zero dollars here well zero
times two is still
zero dollars and then last but not least
instead of four hundred dollars right
over here that times two
is going to be 800 now there's one more
question
that they have below the screen right
over here let me scroll up a little bit
so they tell us matrix d is defined as
follows
d is equal to a plus b what does
matrix d represent so pause the video
and think about that for a second
well if we add two matrices we're going
to add all the corresponding
entries and so what it tells you is what
is the
combined prize for both rounds one and
two based on what the what the
contestant picks and what the host picks
so matrix d that top left entry will
tell you okay in total if the contestant
picked door number one
and the host picked bundle number one
what would you get because it would be a
hundred dollars
plus six hundred dollars so it would be
total for rounds
one and two assuming we don't have the
lightning round like we had
in matrix e